welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of zack
snyder's justice league
while i explain this snyder cuts new
ending and the other changes made from
the theatrical cut in other videos here
i will be combing through this four
howard director's cut for all the
interesting details and easter eggs that
gave this snyder cut such a richer
deeper meaning
superman's opening death cry blasts into
the darkness to awaken the three mother
boxes to alert steppenwolf that earth no
longer has its kryptonian defender
actually back in batman v superman the
alternate angle of this death blow with
doomsday
included this subtle shockwave one of
many examples of how zack snyder's
justice league isn't just a recut
on top of the 2017 version but a true
restoration
of the artistic vision snyder always
intended the shockwave blows past a
daily planet newspaper with the headline
reading
was superman involved which we saw at
the cnn headline in the aftermath of the
capital bombing and batman v superman
and yes by awakening these three mother
boxes superman's death is very much
involved
in iceland arthur's exit is serenaded by
this icelandic folk song
i'm gonna pronounce this all wrong these
are vance and
rosu i'm so sorry it's a traditional
icelandic poem turned lullaby from the
perspective of a woman saying goodbye to
her dream man
kind of reflecting the way arthur begins
this movie as a total heartbreaker
refusing the call to pretty much
everyone
lois leaves the coffee shop passing by a
cameo by zack snyder himself a very meta
cameo since he said he was storyboarding
this exact sequence during this moment
which i don't know how that's possible
since it's already currently
being shot whatever there's a daily
planet headline reading security bank of
manhattan seeks new architect
really that's a front page headline that
a bank needs a new architect
all right and this could be a nod to
green lantern john stewart who
began as an architect jerry the heroes
park cop is a cameo by mark mcclure
jimmy olsen from the donner superman
films he played a central city desktop
in the theatrical cut and steppenwolf
arrives his new design with metallic
armor that opens and closes with
independent shards
similar in a way to the techno-organic
pieces of the motherbox design
and his exchange with the amazonians is
fire i have come
to enlighten you to the great darkness
and we feel each and every heartbreak of
the amazonian sacrifices building up to
the whole freaking vault collapsing into
the sea
snyder re-rendered steppenwolf's blow so
that each of them
spray blood and then vinelli's death now
features
bolts of steppenwolf's axe firing
through her face
as the blade comes down to warn diana
they fire the arrow of artemis which
gets its name from the greek goddess
artemis whom we actually saw
fire the arrow that plunged into
darkseid's chest to keep him from
acquiring the slain green lantern's ring
so the arrow of artemis was really the
key to it all there the sinking fishing
boat is named
the cortlandt a reference to the housing
project and ain rand's the fountainhead
a controversial novel and a favorite of
zack snyder is that he hasn't tried to
adapt for years
arthur chugs the liquor bottle and
throws it into the sea remember
sea pollution was a big plot point
aquaman king orm orders the atlanteans
to spew back all the litter onto the
shores but arthur's move is justified by
an added scene with willem dafoe
as his mentor volkow begging him to take
his mother's trident all the base of the
statue of king atlan
and arthur says that he hates everyone
atlantis anyway so litter away i guess
upon setting up his stronghold
steppenwolf promises to conquer earth
this promise actually becomes his final
spoken words in the final act of this
film right before superman arrives and
wrecks him
for the dark side
diana compliments bruce's flying fox jet
i once knew amanda would have loved to
fly it
a nod of course to her beloved pilot
steve trevor
who returned well sort of via monkey paw
logic and wonder woman 1984 diana
recounts the ancient war against
darkseid and we get to see this it
includes the greek gods of zeus
and artemis and aries you actually see
david lewis's likeness returning from
the first wonder woman the amazonians
are led by hippolyta and robin wright
coming back as antiope the atlanteans
arrive via ship and joining them is a
green lantern this kind of looks like
jalen gur green lantern and this opening
shot shows zeus handing aries the battle
axe that he will later use to deliver
the final blow to darkseid in darkseid's
right
shoulder the same shoulder superman cuts
into on steppenwolf with his heat vision
later
barry allen saves iris west from a crash
including a gardner-fox truck
a reference to gardner-fox comics writer
and co-creator of the flash
barry later tells bruce he feels lonely
and needs friends and this quiet moment
with iris reveals just how his super
speed creates his barrier between him
and the rest of the world
actually later after bruce recruits if
they drive past a billboard reading
you are not alone with the afsp website
it's such an important message for
anyone feeling like they're alone in
their struggles
and of course a reminder of snyder's
late daughter autumn who was such an
inspiration to zack and debbie snyder as
they worked on this recut
and in addition to the four autumn
message at the end cyborg
also joins hands with this deeper theme
against the mother boxes
and i'm not alone another added scene
shows the pair demons dragging
atlanteans out on a beach using a
mechanized starrow to scan their
thoughts steppenwolf also uses it again
later in the tunnel before cyborg
eventually crushes it starro is a dc
parasitic hivemind confirmed to play a
major role in james gunn's suicide squad
later this summer
victor stone's football game scoreboard
was sponsored by wayne enterprises
he is the star of this team and in
batman v superman gotham city university
losing a metropolis
team was a result of his absence his
number is seven
maybe a nod to the early marketing of
unite the seven
for this movie seven justice league
members which this cut finally delivers
by adding martian manhunter to the
lineup there's no green lantern yet just
two dead ones in this movie in victor's
car accident with his mother the
moment of the crash notice how he
reaches across the protector with his
left
arm and later when he awakens in his
cyborg brain the first thing he does is
look at his left hand which is no longer
severed and we also know from the
football scene
from the hand he used to throw the ball
is that this guy is left-handed and this
whole mental tour of his powers depicts
a bull fighting a bear representing a
bull market versus a bear market you
know an economy on the rise versus an
economy in recession
i'm told i don't know economics
otherwise i wouldn't be hustling for
views on youtube
i love his view of everyone's personal
wealth depicted in stacks of cash
and how most of them are moderate height
yet some are randomly sky
high because wealth is hilariously
unevenly distributed something bruce
wayne
loves what are your superpowers again
i'm rich the waitress that victor helps
is linda reed
a reference to the talented archer from
the green arrow comics who commits a
robbery for big bull larsen
back in the apartment there's a poster
for franz kafka's metamorphosis
a nod to the metamorphosis victor has
gone through and the alienation he feels
and just a little design detail i love
his chest light beams through the zipper
of his hoodie because there's little
cracks of daylight there
very cool barry talks to his father
henry allen falsely in prison for
killing barry's mother
laying the groundwork for barry going
back in time to prevent his mother's
murder in the flash movie and in the
flashpoint the paradox is gonna be based
on
and the dialogue here also points in
that direction i can't sit here
and watch you running please in a
flashboy paradox barry time travels by
running on a souped-up treadmill to
build up speed force
running in place henry also says i want
you to make your own
future if you're living in the past make
your own future and barry echoes these
words later when he reverses time
make your own in barry's home rick and
morty plays on a screen in the
background the season one episode
something wicked this way comes which
ends with rick and summer teaming up to
kick the devil's ass
similar to the tag team beat down the
justice league gives steppenwolf there's
also a picture of nicola tesla
the inventor and pioneer seeking to
harness electrical energy in new
ground-breaking ways similar to the way
barry experiments with the speed force
barry also says fluent in sign language
gorilla sign language a nod of course to
the flash villain gorilla
grodd pretty much any time you hear
gorilla's reference in a dc movie it's
gorilla grab
i guess the detective commissioner of
gordon is named crispus
in the credits crispus allen who in the
comics dies and becomes the host body of
the character
spectre an extended atlantis battle
shows mira communicating with other
atlantean outside air bubbles with
squeaks and clicks like the ones used by
dolphins and whales
and when she fights steppenwolf she uses
her water bending powers to suck the
moisture and
the blood out of steppenwolf's body so
cool
steppenwolf tells decide about the
anti-life equation on earth calling it
the key to controlling all life and all
will
throughout the multiverse whoa now
multiverse
implies that these apocalyptians know
about the existence of alternate
realities beyond this one
another sign the dc universe is
branching further outward into alternate
timelines in this coming flash movie and
then darkseid joins the chat and stuff
and wolves armor retracts from his head
in a sign of submission
later when superman heat visions through
his armor it similarly retracts
because this is precisely the moment
superman has him pinned
he's his daddy now victor tells him the
history of the third mother box
item number 61982 a nod to cyborg's
introduction
in dc comics in june 1982. martha meets
with
lois though really this is martian
manhunter john johnson disguised
shifting individually back into his
normal alias of swanwick harry linux
he tells lois that the world needs her
recognizing her as the key to
superman's fate marshman hunter of
course also meets bruce in the final
scene as they dig up clark's corpse
diana says to arthur
an amazon working with an atlantean
how many thousands of years since our
people spoke the amazonians and
allanians have historically hated each
other and
in one of the flashpoint features a war
between these two societies ravages the
earth leaving europe flooded something
we might see in the flash movie now when
they sneak into star labs barry's fake
id
previously had a dumb error in the
theatrical cut listing the birthday as
november 6
2010 meaning he would be like seven
years old here snyder fixed it so that
it is september
30th 1997 which would reflect barry as
like 20 years old but before we continue
building your credit score is hard not
as hard as climbing mount everest but
like way harder than sitting through all
of the snyder cut of justice league
without a bathroom break well pedal is
here to help with your credit score they
don't help with the bathroom stuff
because pedal is a credit card company
that wants to help you succeed
financially that's why the pedal 1 card
is designed to help you build credit
when you apply for pedal one your
banking history is used to instantly
create a cash score
it could help you qualify for a better
credit card even if you've never had a
credit score before the pedal one visa
card has
no annual fee or international
transaction fees their app comes with
some amazing features it lets you link
other financial accounts so that you can
see everything all in one place
you can see if you're pre-approved
without impacting your credit score and
it only takes minutes to apply online
pedal 1 is partnered with web bank
member fdic which issues the cards
as of today the pedal 1 variable aprs
range from 19.99
to 29.49 start building your credit
history go to pedalcard.com
new rockstars today to find out more
that's pedal with the t petal
p-e-t-a-l-card.com new rockstars
in the kryptonian ship one cryopod
remains open as it was when clark found
it in man of steel a design detail that
snyder had added to suggest that some
other kryptonian could be on earth
somewhere
like caraz or l supergirl in lois's
drawer is a pregnancy test and in the
epilogue she now carries a baby basket
instead of a box
and bruce tells clark congratulations
snyder has confirmed that this baby
would have been clark's
and that some future scene would have
involved young bruce
kent being brought into the bat cave set
up at the next batman
victor sees a vision of a dark future
the unity completes earth is scorched
dark side sits atop his throne diana's
body burns on a funeral pyre and the
ruins of the mosquito are overlooked by
darkseid
coins are on her eyes this is a
tradition dating back to ancient greece
the fair paid to carry on for the soul's
delivery across the river styx
darkseid stabs arthur with his own
trident and it is the three-prong
trident of atlan so this would be after
arthur takes the throne in the events of
the aquaman film and darkseid also uses
his omega beams to kill
other atlanteans their corpse just kind
of floating around there black suit
superman cradles the charred corpse
probably of lois and this is in the
batcave you can see robin's suit in the
background there
as darkseid rests his hand on his
shoulder to claim him which is
interesting so he's not using the
anti-life equation to control superman's
mind
superman is turning on the justice
league with his own free will
and then we see the ruins of wayne manor
after its conversion to the hall of
justice
superman hovers over it he's holding the
batman mask that he tore off bruce in
the batman v superman nightmare sequence
and among this rumble a bunch of great
easter eggs first off the corpse of
green lantern kilawog
and then the portrait of thomas wayne
jeffrey dean morgan who may show up as
thomas wayne batman
aquaman's trident diana shield relics
since both of them are dead in this
timeline
and then joker's truce card torn in half
meaning the truce was broken here
so why is victor seeing this it's
because right at this moment barry is
using
time reversal to sync his speed force
with the motherbox at the moment of
fluid contact
and right before that happens is when
cyborg is experiencing this vision so
technically
right after it happened in that precise
moment barry altered the timeline and
that cyborg is a part of that future
history thus
why he witnesses it just like bruce's
vision of batman v superman it happened
as barry again
was altering the timeline by coming back
too soon so
the rule is whenever barry changes the
past those who are part of this future
timeline
experience an echo of the future as it
is being rewritten in that moment
so when clark resurrects the first thing
he sees is his crest
in black on the memorial and during this
fight beside barry on the memorial wall
is the name ben
parker obviously from a different comics
universe but maybe it's a nod to the
expression that no matter what in comics
the ones who stay dead are bucky jason
todd and uncle ben
but with bucky you know that rule got
broken anyway batman says they can track
the third mother box with his satellite
you have a satellite i have six right
ah batman used to have seven satellites
but during superman's battle with zoda
man of steel up in orbit they took
down a wayne enterprises satellite and
it was these events that led to
superman's own fall
leaving it to bruce once again to unite
the seven that's a bit of a stretch but
i think i got there
i mean they could have said it was four
satellites you know superman revisits
the kryptonian ship
passing his red and blue suit the
kryptonian armor worn by zod and then
the kryptonian outpost colonist suit
and he suits up in the black suit as the
nod to the comics this is his
regeneration suit the color black
is better at absorbing solar energy
which is what gives superman his super
strength
this is why he immediately soaks in the
sunlight up in earth's orbit
here we hear the voices of jor-el and
pog kent these two father figures
guiding their son to fly once more
snyder composed all of this even with
hans zimmer's theme as a callback to
that first flight and man of steel and
as superman arrives in the fight against
steppenwolf composer junkie xl who did
amazing work rescoring this whole film
kicks in with this triumphant coda to
the man of steel theme
every hit superman delivers on
steppenwolf releases a shockwave echoing
the shockwaves of his dying breaths in
the opening scene
but missing his window barry has to use
super speed to reverse time once more
and i love how the crumbling terrain
re-materializes with every step as he
outruns
the reverse destruction conveying how it
is this literal running
that stitches the world back together
and we see the gross
flesh of superman and cyborg
re-materializing and i specifically love
that they do this for victor
to remind us of his remaining humanity
that's still in his cyborg body and it
is that humanity that helps victor see
the motherbox illusions as what they are
sadly you could say it is the fact that
his father silas is actually there
that's the red flag when in reality you
know he's a no-show
and i love how the mother boxes are
briefly shown as these white-haired
demons since you know they are not just
tech they were describing them earlier
as
living things and with the unity
separated the god-powered justice league
members deliver an amazing one two three
fatality on steppenwolf with actually
the fourth and final blow delivered by
darkseid he's flanked by desaad and
granny goodness who in the comics is the
one who trains darkseid soldiers the
epilogue is narrated by silastone the
voice recording victor previously
smashed
i love how it encourages him to take his
place as a hero which in a way parallels
jor-el's recorded message to his son
ryan choi takes over star labs as the
future dc hero of the
atom batman stands atop his war machine
tank from the dark knight returns and if
you look closely at the shot the mutant
gang that batman pursued in that comic
series is all tied up in headlights
there
lex luthor escapes arkham with its sign
out front reading home for the
emotionally troubled which is the
cynical name frank miller gave it in the
dark knight returns and also says built
in 1974
a nod to arkham asylum's first
appearance in the comics in october
1974.
lexel's deathstroke batman's name is
bruce wayne which was meant to set up
the batman film when it was still going
to be written and directed and starred
in by ben affleck with joe manganiello
as deathstroke
obviously it's no longer case with matt
reeves robert pattinson batman movie
that's basically a complete rewrite of
that
but now in this epilogue scene
deathstroke joins batman
in this post-apocalyptic future along
with cyborg armored flash and mira
along with jared leto joker joker wears
a swat fest much like he did when we
last saw him at the end of suicide squad
covered with police badges worn like
trophies of the cops he probably killed
he has no tattoos but interesting scars
across his face
we might be looking at an alternate
timeline version of the joker because he
does ask bruce
how many alternate timelines do you
destroy the world because you don't have
the kones to die yourself
during this joker taunt batman about
killing robin and notice how snyder lets
joker go
more and more out of focus as batman's
just staring more at that card and
trying to ignore
joker's teasing until the moment joker
crosses the line to snap him into focus
like why you sent to boy wonder
to do a man's job now joker's truce card
is actually the same joker design as the
joker card that appeared in batman
number
one going way way way back there this is
a sign of the truce between them to
never bring up this bad blood because if
they do
they're gonna start fighting this
explains why batman had that joker card
taped to his gun and batman v superman
and that card being torn and vick's
vision
tells us that in at least one of these
futures batman says screw it he tears
the card he lets joker cackle on about
killing robin and then beats a joker to
death but that would be mission
failure for batman he can't do that he
needs joker to change his mind in the
past
to spare lois and prevent her horrific
death in the bat cave prevent superman
from turning on batman
and the justice league and helping
darkseid conquer earth and after
many many failures it sounds like batman
has finally found joker's key
hardly quinn because notice right as
batman brings up harley joker suddenly
looks stunned he even trembles
before he says you're good
he almost had me so while this timeline
may have hit a dead end with superman's
arrival
batman barry and the others now might
have a new tactic
on their next timeline reset to find
harley quinn
joker's love and use her as leverage to
stop this madman from letting the world
burn
and after bruce meets martian manhunter
snyder fades to black on for
autumn as a cover of leonard cohen's
alleluia plays he said this was his late
daughter autumn's favorite song and
there's a song whose lyrics tell the
story of a heartbroken artist
just struggling to find meaning in the
rote chanting of a church him
a struggle that zack snyder could
certainly relate with as he completed
this project that was so
close to his heart you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything you love
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
[Music]
you